Chicago amaneció con la peor calidad del
aire de todo el mundo y con un Horizonte
parcialmente oscurecido por el humo de
los incendios forestales en Canadá estos
días varias ciudades norteamericanas han
sido afectadas como Nueva York bitsberg
y Detroit causando contaminación y
preocupación entre los residentes en
total más de 100 millones de
estadounidenses estaban lidiando con la
mala calidad del aire en la tarde del
miércoles
hoy he visto a alguien corriendo y le he
dicho Oye de más despacio ponte una
mascarilla no te esfuerces demasiado
Cuanto más respiras y Cuanto más fuerte
respiras estás inhalando literalmente un
fuego humo de campamento en tus pulmones
Así que
este humo viajó desde Canadá donde los
incendios arrasan desde hace varias
semanas de este bosque por ejemplo solo
quedan árboles carbonizados tierra negra
y un humo espeso ya se han quemado más
de siete millones de hectáreas en el
país y los incendios han liberado
representa miga toneladas de emisiones
de carbono un récord eso es más del 10%
del total de las emisiones mundiales del
año pasado
en términos de consecuencias climáticas
también hayosina y carbono negro que con
el flujo atmosférico adecuado puede
acabar en el Ártico puede asentarse en
el hielo o en la capa de hielo de
Groenlandia lo que potencialmente puede
acelerar el deshielo y contribuir al
calentamiento global
los científicos están preocupados ya que
las emisiones continúan a escala masiva
en todo el país en Canadá más de 250
incendios permanecen fuera de control